we have reached today an important
decision in good cooperation between the
government and the president of the
republic
we hope that the parliament will confirm
the decision to apply for nato
membership during the coming days
to be frank i'm a bit confused
because i had a telephone discussion
with the president earlier on that is
approximately a month ago
and
actually he took up himself before i had
a possibility to do that that you're
applying for nato membership
and we will assess it favorable
i thanked him
and he was very pleased
receiving my thanks
so
you can understand that i'm a bit
confused
what we heard
two days ago was different then
yesterday
we again heard that
turkey is open to our membership but
it turned back to no or
let's say negative side
i i think that
what we need now is a very clear answer
i'm prepared to have a new discussion
with president erdogan about
the problems he has raised
of course when we look at russia we we
see very different kind of russia today
than we saw
just few months ago everything has
changed when russia attacked ukraine and
i personally think that we cannot trust
anymore that there will be peaceful
future
next to russia
with our own that's why we're making the
decisions to joining nato it's act of
peace that there would ever again be war
in finland in the future we have had
wars with russia and we don't want that
kind of future for ourselves for our
children and this is why we're making
these these decisions today and upcoming
week so there would never again be war
infinite